did she just make full eye contact  definitely knowing behind me you want a  free sample  do you like to cook they go great on  pies or on salads and they're  gluten-free  sounds like she's taking an interest in  my personal life well do you live with  anyone should you buy for two Oh is she  trying to figure out if I'm single she  could just be trying to sell me apples  you know has anyone ever told you you  look like another person I do look like  a relatable Matt Damon normally I could  only get people one free sample but he  can have as many as one does that mean  what I think it means there is a great  bar just around the corner that I go to  all the time you should totally check it  out okay when whenever all right I mean  that's a clear invitation definitely  gonna ask her out next week so good to  meet you Patrick right Peter  you came back so good to see you have as  many free samples as you want you go  check out that bar  you